Speaker 1: This is absolutely the best. I hope you
enjoy this. So yesterday there was a protest or a
rally in lower Manhattan near where presumably
Donald Trump would be arrested and booked if
indeed that happens. Right. Side broadcasting was
covering it live. We covered it live and it was
just a complete and total mess. Barely anybody
showed up. There seemed to be more media than
there were actual protesters. It was wild. Right
side broadcasting is doing interviews and while
of right side broadcasting is interviewing a
young guy draped in some kind of flag wearing
a red MAGA hat. Jason from The Good Liars,
which is this satirical left wing comedy duo,
they've done really, really good stuff in the
past. Slowly, Jason from The Good Liars who,
if you're watching right now, you see a sort of
like screen, right? Jason drifts into the shot
and the kid who's being interviewed
immediately recognizes Jason and says,
Oh, the good liars. The interviewer from right
side broadcasting apparently doesn't know what the
good liars is. Who they are, doesn't recognize
Jason and Jason just brutally trolls that the
protest was totally flaccid. And I know that
technically the word is pronounced flaccid,
but nobody says it that way. So I'm going to
continue saying flaccid so people know it was
like a wet noodle protest. Totally pathetic.
Jason slips in and it's just you have to see
the execution here. Let's take a.
Speaker 2: Look. Minors and
some misdemeanors, two felonies.
Speaker 3: And specifically prosecuting Donald
Trump. When he didn't, he did very little wrong.
Speaker 2: If anything, he's prosecuting around
the city right now. I mean,
there's crime everywhere.
Speaker 3: Hey, good liars. What's up?
Speaker 1: So the kid immediately recognizes
him and says, Hey, the good liars, what's up?
And Jason just tries to shake his hand and keep
going. The interviewer has no clue what's going
on. And this this. This is just so well done.
Speaker 2: Hey, good to see you. Yeah, there's
good. There's crime everywhere. And I think,
like, this is a political prosecution. It has to
be right. Like, that's that. That's the only way
it could be happening right now is if they're
going after him. Political. Politically,
the only other option is that Donald Trump
lost by 7 million votes and is a loser who
can't deal with the fact that he lost the election
because he based his whole personality on being a
winner and calling people losers. So his.
Speaker 4: So is you think his attitude,
his approach, his personality is what is.
Speaker 2: Is is what got us in this mess
in the first place potentially. Or I'm just going
to choose to believe that the election was stolen
and everything that he says, the.
Speaker 1: Interviewer
has no idea what's going on.
Speaker 2: Because I kind of like first
base my whole personality. I'm supporting Donald
Trump, so I'm not going to maybe accept the fact.
Speaker 4: You live in you live in the city.
So how's the city changed over the last
couple of years here? I mean, I know crime,
but I don't live here, so I don't I can't
judge when that goes. Is going up or down.
Speaker 2: Yeah. New York City, I think,
is maybe 59th in crime right now. I think
there's four cities in Indiana that has have
more crime specifically than New York.
Speaker 1: And the kid next to Jason,
who's really a MAGA guy, knows exactly what's
going on, but he's allowing this to continue,
which is just amazing.
Speaker 2: Mark does. Yeah,
exactly. So I haven't really noticed a lot
of crime, but I do see it on, you know,
Fox News. They say it's it's much more dangerous
now. I don't I haven't seen it. I haven't seen
any more crime. So like, maybe that's it might not
be true, but I'm going to choose to believe that
it is true because I did see that on Fox there.
Speaker 4: Of course. Because whatever you see
on Fox News is true. Right? And just like
CNN and MSNBC, if you see it on if you see
it on cable news, it's got to be true.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump says CNN and
MSNBC are fake news.
Speaker 4: That's
right. We got to use a fake news.
Speaker 1: Yep. Okay. So and then
just one more clip here. And this is just
so brilliantly. But he's asked to weigh
in about like the size of the of the rally.
And he he also slips in some good stuff here.
Speaker 4: So, I mean, what's
your take on it so far? I mean,
there's a lot of people out here. Yeah.
Speaker 2: It seems like there's a lot of media.
I would say just basically all media and I guess
there's Bret is a Braxton Braxton. And then I see
another guy who seems like there's about ten
Trump supporters here, mostly media. Yeah. So.
Speaker 1: Oh, man, this is just
absolutely fantastic. And you know,
the other the other really funny thing in general
about this is that the Trump sort of like asked
supporters to be ready to protest or whatever
the case may be. They're not seeming like that,
willing to do it. Interestingly enough,
except a few did go out front to Trump
Tower. And I think it's quite literally five
people and a woman blows a shofar server.
So there are one, two, three,
four, I guess five or six people,
two holding Trump, one signs and one
woman blows a shofar. And that's what
they were able to sort of coalesce at Trump
Tower. This is starting to become surreal,
as if it hasn't been surreal for the last
six days. It is unbelievable what is going
on here. And that's not even counting what
Donald Trump Jr's last 24 hours look like